[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers
in allen guten Abend die Retter wollen
nicht aufgeben aber immer seltener
werden ihre Erfolgsmeldungen deutsche
und britische Helfer haben vergangene
Nacht eine Mutter und ihre sechs Jahre
alte Tochter befreit aus den Trümmern
ihres eingestürzten Hauses
währenddessen irren jetzt die vierte
Nacht in Folge Menschen ziellos durch
die Straßen im Erdbebengebiet weil es zu
kalt ist um zu sitzen und weil sie
keinen Ort haben an den sie gehen
könnten das Ausmaß der Verwüstung können
wir uns auf Luftbildern ansehen wirklich
zu fassen ist all das nicht unsere
reporterin Anne brüll ist in Adana
sie suchen etwas dass sie an ihre
Liebsten erinnert
Kinderfotos ein Hochzeitsbild
alle Sachen haben Helfer aus den
Trümmern retten können und vorsortiert
aus dem was mal ein Hochhaus war mit 13
Stockwerken bis am Montagmorgen die Erde
bebte auch in Andernach
irmax Verwandte sind hier gestorben sie
hat ihr Foto auf dem Handy
es waren vier Bruder Schwägerin zwar
Nichten habe ich verloren eine von ihnen
wird noch vermisst
seit Tagen harren sie hier aus warten
darauf dass die Retter wieder einen
toten Bergen wollen einfach nur
Gewissheit
unsere Verwandten haben da gewohnt sie
waren zu viert Enkel Tochter Vater und
Mutter
Wüste und nebenan ist alles stehen
geblieben die Nachbarn glauben dass am
eingestürzten Hochhaus an den
Baumaterialien gespart wurde
für den Beton haben sie Sand von
schlechter Qualität verwendet links
sieht man ein Gebäude vom gleichen
Bauunternehmen auch das ist nicht mehr
bewohnbar
in einem Park mitten in Adana hat der
türkische Katastrophenschutz zählte
errichtet für die deren Häuser
einsturzgefährdet sind wir treffen im
ran Alton die mit ihren Töchtern seit
Montag hier ist Elif zeigt uns das Zelt
ich schlafe hier wir schlafen hier links
es wird manchmal sehr kalt so dass wir
sogar zittern müssen
schwierig weil wir uns nicht aufwärmen
können das ist ein Zelt das zieht rein
es wurden zwar Decken verteilt aber das
war nicht ausreichend
die Rettungsarbeiten in der Stadt laufen
weiter noch will hier niemand der vielen
freiwilligen aufgeben
ich kann nicht zu Hause bleiben das tut
mir weh weil mein Herz und meine Seele
hier vor Ort sind
und sie einfach nichts unversucht lassen
wollen
wir haben gerade noch eine Leiche
ausgegraben und wir haben noch eine
Stimme gehört aber sind uns nicht sicher
das Rettungsteam überprüft das
entgegen aller Wahrscheinlichkeit hoffen
Sie in Ada immer noch auf ein Wunder
über 20.000 tote das ist die aktuelle
schreckliche Zahl aus dem Erdbebengebiet
die natürlich auch alle die
niederschmettert die dort Familie haben
Verwandte Freunde und die ist nicht mehr
aushalten nur aus der Ferne zuzusehen
alle helfen allen das Motto einer guten
Nachbarschaft Sven Regen aus Hamburg wir
können hier vorne anfangen
betreut in Hamburg Migranten junge
Menschen kurdischer und türkischer
Abstammung er hilft Ihnen bei der
Eingliederung in die deutsche
Gesellschaft jetzt braucht er Hilfe Geld
für sein Heimatdorf das nicht mehr steht
für seine Familie Freunde Verwandte die
nichts mehr haben
ich komme selber aus Passage ich bin
dort aufgewachsen ich habe auch dort
meine Kindheitsfreunde verloren
Familienangehörige verloren auch mein
Dorf ist es jetzt liegt in Trümmern die
Katastrophe lässt alle enger
zusammenrücken Vereine Organisationen
und Institutionen in der türkischen
Gemeinde sitzen sie zusammen eine
schnell organisierte und leicht
improvisierte Spenden Sammelsendung
Facebook und Youtube als hilfsmedium
alles verbunden mit der einen Botschaft
zur Zeit hilft vor Ort nur Geld 200000 €
waren es hier am Ende
in den 99er Erdbeben haben wir das auch
erlebt da ist das meiste was ein
Sachspenden gekommen ist leider
in den Depots verschimmelt das ist an
die Menschen nicht gekommen
dementsprechend bleibt uns im Moment nur
die Möglichkeit
finanziell monetär zu helfen das
Bauchgefühl sagt etwas anderes irgendwie
helfen irgendwie mit anpacken und wenn
es nur für später ist szenen wie diese
finden sich überall in Hamburg überall
in Deutschland am besten in der Schuhe
oder Kindersachen warme Kleidung
deckenhygieneartikel sortiert und
erfasst damit die Lieferung vielleicht
doch durch den türkischen Zoll kommt das
lenkt ab leider ist es auch so dass von
uns natürlich auch Familienangehörige
betroffen sind ja die kriegen die leider
nicht erreicht und so bauen wir unseren
Frust oder unsere Trauer ab
wo ist die Kette Leute Speditionen wie
die von Volkan kisachi und Shanghai
trauen sich die Tour zu sie fahren
normalerweise nur in Deutschland der
Hamburger Konsul aber hat ihnen
versichert sie kommen durch deshalb ist
der Transport jetzt Ihre Spende im Lager
keine Kleidung nur Hygieneartikel Decken
und Zelte seit 1 Januar schon lässt die
Türkei keine gebrauchte Kleidung mehr
ins Land unser Land ist das eine
Packliste ausreicht und ein also die
Verzollung in Deutschland durchgeführt
und in also es wurde es ist wirklich
eine Notsituation in der Türkei und ich
glaube jede Hilfe für jede Hilfe sind
sie dankbar sie packen solange es eben
dauert irgendwann heute Nacht startet
der Truck den Osten vier Tage mit zwei
Fahrern Erfolg ungewiss aber auf der
anderen Seite der Grenze überhaupt
jemand verteilen kann wissen sie nicht
sie packen an für alle anderen sagen die
Hilfsorganisationen sind Geldspenden das
Beste in der aktuellen Lage wenn Sie
also helfen wollen dann geht das unter
anderem beim Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe hier ist die
Kontonummer iban.de
65100-400-100 400 das Stichwort ZDF
Erdbeben Türkei Syrien und Informationen
bekommen Sie auch unter Spenden zdf.de
oder im ZDF Text auf Seite 890 bei der
Not in Syrien stehen nicht nur die
Hilfsorganisationen nochmal vor
zusätzlichen Herausforderungen das
gesamte Ausmaß der Katastrophe dort ist
noch nicht einmal in Ansätzen klar das
Land ist zersplittert der Nordwesten
Syriens wird kontrolliert durch Milizen
Gegner des Assad-Regimes in damaskos der
Schrecken des Bürgerkriegs ist nicht
vorbei aber tausende waren dort schon
vor dem Erdbeben auf der Flucht und ohne
richtige bleibe sie stehen jetzt wieder
vor den Trümmern ihrer Existenz in der
Region edlib ist Hoffnung zu einem
leeren Wort geworden es war schon vorher
schwer überhaupt nur in diese Gegend zu
kommen
und wir erreichen jetzt in Idlib Hassan
Alam er ist bei der Hilfsorganisation
Hand in Hand vor development and eight
Herr Alarm schönen guten Abend
wie viel Hilfe erreicht sie denn aktuell
im Nordwesten von Syrien
seit drei Tagen hatten wir
Schwierigkeiten natürlich wir haben sehr
hart daran gearbeitet den Menschen zu
helfen also Leute zu retten das war
ziemlich harte Arbeit wir haben sie
gehört wir haben Stimmen gehört von
unter den Steinen unter den Trümmern wo
wir sie vermuten und man hört sie und
man kann ihn nicht helfen das ist sehr
sehr schlimm diese Situation wir haben
keine wirkliche Ausrüstung keine
Maschinen wir mussten tatsächlich alles
nehmen was wir irgendwie hatten also mit
unseren bloßen Händen haben wir gegraben
und und versucht die Leute zu befreien
und wir hoffen jetzt tatsächlich das
Meer an Hilfe kommt und auch an schwerem
Gerät dass wir unbedingt brauchen wir
haben das Gefühl dass wir sehr viel mehr
Leute hätten retten können wenn wir
schon vorher das Material gehabt hätten
wenn wir Geräte gehabt hätten wir haben
Tausende von Toten wir haben tausende
von Verletzten den wir viel besser
hätten helfen können
was sind denn die größten Hindernisse
die es im Moment gibt
sind wir
natürlich weiterhin dabei zu versuchen
Leute zu retten so schnell wie möglich
und jetzt jetzt versuchen wir natürlich
den
Leuten zu helfen die noch überlebt haben
aber im Moment Bergen wir eigentlich nur
noch tote Menschen wir versuchen
diejenigen zu unterstützen die jetzt
draußen überleben müssen es ist
unheimlich kalt es ist -4 - 5 Grad
nachts wir versuchen also denjenigen zu
helfen die Nacht sich durchschlagen
müssen wir versuchen ihn decken zu geben
Matratzen in ein bisschen ein Dach über
dem Kopf zubereiten mit irgendwelchen
Materialien die wir bekommen können
alles ist irgendwie knapp aber wir wir
versuchen das Beste wir haben einfach zu
wenig das ist unser größtes Problem der
Strom ist nicht mehr da seit vier Tagen
kein Strom und
sind jetzt kommt das so langsam wieder
und es gibt ja weiterhin wirklich nicht
genügend was kommt aus dem Rest der Welt
also wir warten immer noch dass die
Hilfe anläuft
aber heute haben wir gute Nachrichten
erhalten nämlich dass es einen Konvoi
geben soll es wurde uns bestätigt dass
die Grenze
ab gestern Abend oder oder heute morgen
offen ist und das dann tatsächlich
Lastwagen durchgekommen sind dass da ein
Konvoi kommt und dass da Material von
der anderen Seite der Grenze rüberkommt
beschreiben ist ja Verzweiflung in einem
Ausmaß dass man sich nicht mehr ausmalen
kann hier bei uns eine Gegend die sie
haben es gesagt gezeichnet ist von zwölf
Jahren Bürgerkrieg Flucht Vertreibung
kann man damit dem Wort Hoffnung
überhaupt noch etwas anfangen
in unserer Arbeit fühlen wir uns relativ
hilflos wir waren eigentlich schon
vorher ziemlich hilflos und verzweifelt
aber nach diesem Erdbeben ist es noch
einmal ein Schlag gewesen für alle noch
ein stärkerer Schlag wir führen uns noch
hilfloser man man sieht die Leute die
sterben sie schreien nach Hilfe man kann
ihn nicht helfen es ist eine absolute
Katastrophe für alle die hier wohnen
eine Katastrophe für uns dass wir die
Leute sehen die wollen dass wir Ihnen
helfen und wir können Ihnen einfach
nicht helfen und jetzt soll Hilfe kommen
und wir hoffen wirklich ganz ganz stark
dass das kommt denn wir warten seit über
drei Tagen und wir kämpfen so hart und
wir versuchen das Problem irgendwie zu
lösen
der Appell eines hilflosen Helfers
hasanalarm von der Hilfsorganisation
hand in hand for development and aid in
eclip Herr Lam vielen Dank
danke
dass ich in der Sendung sein durfte und
dass Sie mir zugehört haben unsere Seite
der Geschichte gehört haben
besprechen was technischen Gründen vor
der Sendung aufgezeichnet und so viel
zunächst zu dem verheerenden Erdbeben
unser nächstes Thema heute Abend kein
wichtiges polit-treffen dass die Akteure
nicht selbst versuchen möglichst
vorteilhaft ins Bild zu setzen ohne
eigenes Social Media Team glaubt ja
keine Regierung mehr auszukommen die
Macht der Bilder ist unbestritten wenn
symbolhafte Aufnahmen allerdings
geradezu am Fließband produziert werden
lohnt es sich doppelt hinter die
Inszenierung zu schauen auf das was
tatsächlich passiert der Unterschied ist
gewaltig heute in Brüssel wo man fast
den Eindruck haben konnte die Ukraine
sei bereits Mitglied der EU Präsident
wurde mir selenski auf Europa Reise was
er will ist klar mehr Waffen auch
Flugzeuge und einen schnellen Beitritt
was Europa bietet ist weit weniger klar
wie Florian neu anzeigt
sie sind aus ihren Büros gekommen für
ein Handyfoto oder wenigstens einen
Blick da kommt an diesem Morgen
schließlich nicht irgendwer im ihr
EU-Parlament sondern ein Präsident aus
dem Krieg er wird empfangen wie ein
Popstar und Woody mir selensky liefert
Ruhm der Ukraine den Helden Ruhm
[Applaus]
von den Tränen der Ergriffenheit bis
später zu den Lachern als er den
Präsidenten des Europäischen Rats fest
zu nageln versucht auf den Start von
EU-Beitrittsverhandlungen
wenn ich dieses Jahr sage meine ich
dieses Jahr
aber zwischendrin ist da dieser eine
Moment wo der Druck deutlich wird der
auf ihm und dieser Reise lastet
Januar Bravo ich habe einfach kein Recht
wieder nach Hause zu reisen ohne ein
Ergebnis
heute erstmal bietet Symbole durchaus
historische die Hymne seines Landes
abgespielt im Europa-Parlament dann beim
EU-Gipfel Umarmungen der Staats- und
regierungs- aber will mehr Kampfjets
etwa in Brüssel sprechen sich heute vor
allem jene dafür aus die selbst über
keine Flieger verfügen
[Musik]
und jetzt müssen die Staaten schnell den
nächsten Schritt erwägen
Langstreckenwaffen und Kampfjets zu
liefern
die Sie brauchen um die Freiheit zu
verteidigen
bewegt sich da wirklich etwas es ist
selensky selbst der diesen Eindruck am
Nachmittag erweckt
ich habe von vielen europäischen Führern
gehört dass sie bereit sind uns die
nötigen Waffen zukommen zu lassen auch
Flugzeuge
welche Länder das sein sollen aber sagt
er nicht zumal ja vor diesem nächsten
Schritt vielleicht erst der letzte
umgesetzt werden sollte die Lieferung
von Leopard Kampfpanzern angeführt von
Deutschland stockt der Kanzler
verteidigt sich
wir sind sehr schnell und Deutschland
leistet ein ganz zentralen Beitrag dazu
dass wir eine schnelle Unterstützung
gewährleisten Europa hat diesen Mann
heute gefeiert doch die wichtigste Frage
bleibt am Abend offen was wo Leute mir
selenski nach Hause mitbringen
ja aber die Frage wollen wir jetzt noch
mal reden Bilder wirken Bilder brennen
sich ein manchmal kommt man hinter
bestimmte Bilder auch nicht mehr wieder
zurück gucken wir also auf die Fakten
mit ultra guten Abend nach Brüssel Ulf
Wiener ist denn der Beitritt der Ukraine
zur EU jetzt tatsächlich
als wenn man mit Diplomaten und
Politikern spricht die heute nicht im
Rampenlicht sich mit silensky gesandt
haben sondern in Maschinenraum sind und
dort eben den EU-Beitritt organisieren
müssen dann gibt es eine sehr einfache
und deutliche Antwort das ist noch viele
viele Jahre dauern wird bis die Ukraine
vielleicht einmal der EU Beitritt das
sind sie sehr sehr skeptisch und es wird
gewarnt eben auch von diesen Diplomaten
nicht zu hohe Erwartung zu erzeugen wie
das heute der Fall war weil diese
Erwartung werden mit Sicherheit bitter
enttäuscht was ist der Grund für das
doch das ist so lange dauert es geht ihm
um das große Thema Korruption da muss
die Ukraine gewisse Kriterien erfüllen
und davon ist sie noch weit entfernt
auch wenn man hier anerkennt dass sogar
ein Kriegszeiten die Ukraine ist
geschafft hat diese Gruppen ein bisschen
einzudämmen aber eben nur ein bisschen
so fern wird es noch eine ganze ganze
Weile dauern jenseits der wunderbaren
Bilder
das war dann heute auch von Präsident
selenski hier wieder ein dringender
Appell mehr Waffen zu liefern und
gleichzeitig sagte er über den
Bundeskanzler der einer der größten
Waffenlieferanten der Ukraine ist heute
in einem Spiegel-Interview ich zitiere
da mal wörtlich ich also ich selensky
muss Druck machen der Ukraine zu helfen
und Scholz ständig überzeugen dass diese
Hilfe nicht für uns ist sondern für die
Europäer wie schwer fällt es denn Europa
auf die Wünsche und bitten aus Kiew eine
gemeinsame Antwort zu finden also auch
wieder jenseits der wunderbaren Bilder
glaube ich gibt es diese gemeinsame
Haltung nicht wir haben das ja erlebt
bei der panzerdebatte wie schwierig das
war für Europa dazu ein Beschluss zu
kommen und wenn man ehrlich ist gibt es
zwar jetzt ein Beschluss aber es gibt
immer noch keine Kampfpanzer die werden
wahrscheinlich so spät geliefert dass
die russische Offensive schon lange Gang
ist und viele machen nicht mit das
gleiche ist jetzt absehbar bei den
Kampfjets es gibt die Osteuropäer es
gibt die Balken die fordern das und dann
gibt es eben Ausländer wie Deutschland
allen voran aber auf Frankreich die
Kampfjets für äußerst problematisch
halten und das eben nicht wollen sie
haben Angst dass das eine neue Qualität
des und eben die Eskalation mit Russland
absolut erhöht diese Gefahr deswegen
gibt es diesen Unterschied und ich
glaube der wird sich auch nicht auflösen
ich habe eher das Gefühl dass in dieser
Frage Olaf Scholz sehr hart bleiben will
ultra ZDF Brüssel vielen Dank Ulf und
jetzt hier in die Innenpolitik mit Diana
ganz genau der Bundestag hat am
Vormittag über das 49 euro-ticket für
Bus und Bahn debattiert dabei ging es
vor allem um die Finanzierung des
Vorhabens das Anfang Mai starten soll
der Bund will dafür in diesem und den
kommenden zwei Jahren jeweils 1,5
Milliarden Euro bereitstellen genauso
wie die Länder Kritik am Deutschland
Ticket äußerte unter anderem die Union
so sei die Finanzierung nicht
langfristig gesichert die AFD bemängelte
dass das Ticket nicht für neue Linien
Sorge immer allgemeine die
Inflationsrate in Deutschland ist wieder
leicht gestiegen das gab das
Statistische Bundesamt bekannt im Januar
lag sie bei 8,7 Prozent und damit 0,1%
Punkte höher als im Dezember allerdings
ist der Anstieg damit geringer als von
Expertinnen und Experten befürchtet im
Dezember hatte der Staat die
Abschlagszahlungen für Gas und Fernwärme
übernommen und so die Verbraucherpreise
gedrückt ja und wegen der anhaltend
hohen Inflation fordern die
Beschäftigten im öffentlichen Dienst von
Bund und Kommunen deutlich mehr lohnen
in mehreren Bundesländern gab es heute
Warnstreiks Mitarbeiter von
Verkehrsbetrieben Krankenhäusern oder
Kitas demonstrierten wie hier in
Düsseldorf Ziel der Gewerkschaften ist
ein Lohnplus von 10,5 Prozent mindestens
aber monatlich 500 Euro mehr für die
rund 2,5 Millionen Beschäftigten
nach Angaben der US-Regierung soll China
Spionage Balance in mehr als 40 Ländern
auf fünf Kontinenten eingesetzt haben
der am Samstag vom US-Militär
abgeschossene Balance habe über mehrere
Antennen verfügt und sei vermutlich in
der Lage gewesen
kommunikationssignale abzugreifen und zu
lokalisieren er gehöre zu einer Flotte
von chinesischen Balance die für
überwachungszwecke entwickelt worden
sein China wie ist die Vorwürfe zurück
und warf den USA vor einen
Informationskrieg zu führen
nach der chaos-wahl in Berlin ist am
Sonntag
Wahlwiederholung dort diesmal
hoffentlich so ordentlich wie es zu
einer Demokratie gehört die neuesten
Zahlen heute Abend vom ZDF
Politbarometer dazu sehen so aus wenn
schon heute Abgeordnetenhauswahl wäre
dann läge die oppositionelle CDU vorn
mit 25% vor SPD Grünen und Linken die
aktuell eine Regierungs Koalition bilden
CDU bei einer Berlinwahl an der Spitze
das hat es in diesem Jahrhundert noch
nie gegeben aber um regieren zu können
braucht sie Koalitionspartner und auch
für die bisherige Koalition wäre nach
diesen Zahlen eine Mehrheit drin sprich
es wird spannend Stefan Merseburger und
Markus groß
Wahlkampf kurz vor der Zielgeraden
gestern Abend das Trier die drei die
anfangschancen auf den Chefposten in
Berlin hatten Preisen sich ich möchte
diese Arbeit die ich jetzt für
weitermachen ich war bekannt war ich
möchte aber dass wir es schaffen eine
Stadt gemeinsam zu bauen in der es eine
gute Zukunft gibt ich möchte gerne dass
diese Stadt wieder funktioniert Kai
Wegner verspricht bessere Schulen freie
Fahrt für Autofahrer und mehr innere
Sicherheit Hendrik wüst ist gekommen
Unterstützung aus Düsseldorf für den
Berliner CDU Spitzenkandidaten Wegner er
führt in allen Umfragen doch es sieht so
aus als sei ein König ohne Land denn
weder SPD noch Grüne wollen ihm den
Steigbügel halten
kann mir gar nicht vorstellen dass
womöglich die Wahlverlierer eine
Koalition weitermachen und von daher
gucke ich mit Demut mit Respekt auch mit
Spannung auf den Wahlamt und was die
Berlinerinnen und Berliner sich wünschen
die FDP wünscht sich mit CDU und SPD zu
regieren unwahrscheinlich die AFD könnte
zweistellig abschneiden und Klaus
lederers Linke hat gute Chancen wieder
mit Sozialdemokraten und Grünen zu
regieren
Spitzenkandidatin Bettina jarasch will
solch eine Koalition anführen doch das
könnte schwierig werden Giffey liegt vor
der Grünen ihre Themen Verkehrswende
Klima und eine Verwaltungsreform
die Verwaltungsreform ist die Grundlage
von allem anderen die Stadt muss
funktionieren die Bürger müssen ihre
Dienstleistungen in jedem Bezirk schnell
und auf die gleiche Weise kriegen ewige
Wartezeiten auf Termine bei Bürgerämtern
unklare Zuständigkeiten blockieren
wichtige Vorhaben Berlins Verwaltung
funktioniert nicht seit mittlerweile 20
Jahren
jetzt will die Koalition die Verwaltung
reformieren endlich das ist ein Signal
Rot-Grün-Rot will nach der Wahl
weitermachen
dafür muss ihre SPD mindestens auf dem
zweiten Platz über die Ziellinie gehen
Franziska Giffey kämpft um das Rote
Rathaus verliert sie es ist auch ihre
Zukunft ungewiss
das Rote Rathaus muss rot bleiben weil
es eine soziale und demokratische Kraft
in Führung in dieser Stadt braucht weil
wir die ganze Stadt im Blick haben und
sozialen ökologischen aber auch
wirtschaftlichen Fortschritt zusammen
denken nicht siegen und trotzdem das
Rathaus verteidigen gewinnen ohne zu
regieren
verlieren und trotzdem weiter mit
regieren alles möglich der Wahlsonntag
in Berlin wird spannend
trotz schwächelnder Konjunktur zeigt
sich der DAX-Konzern Siemens aktuell
mehr als robust das Unternehmen meldet
heute ein Umsatzplus von 8% und damit
einen starken Staat ins neue
Geschäftsjahr Valerie Haller und diese
positiven Nachrichten haben dann auch
den DAX ganz schön beflügelt stimmt
siemens hat ja auch in der laufenden
Berichtssaison tatsächlich ziemlich
stark schon vorgelegt in diesen Tagen
veröffentlichen ja einige Dax-Konzerne
ihre Zahlen Siemens zeigt seine neue
Stärke mitten in der Konjunktur Flaute
strotzt vor Zuversicht denn auch die
Auftragsbücher sind prall gefüllt ja und
Zug fährt bei Siemens ist das
digitalisierungsgeschäft wie hier in
einer Siemens Fabrik in Amberg übernimmt
die künstliche Intelligenz selbstständig
Arbeitsschritte produziert jede Sekunde
ein fertiges Produkt und nur wenn
Probleme auftreten schreitet der Mensch
ein wir genau dieser Art von Industrie
Automatisierung macht das Unternehmen
gerade das große Geschäft siemens
entwickelt sich
wachstumsstarken digitalkonzern das
überzeugt auch Anleger und die machen
Siemens heute zum DAX Primus der
erreichte zwischendurch selbst ein
Jahreshoch kann es zwar nicht halten
beendet den Tag aber trotzdem fest da
wichtige Personalie im DAX-Konzern Bayer
der langjährige Chef Baumann tritt Ende
Mai vorzeitig ab seit der Übernahme des
amerikanischen Saatgut riesen Monsanto
stand der langjährige
Vorstandsvorsitzende unter Druck denn
Bayer ist seither in einen
milliardenschweren Rechtsstreit
verwickelt Baumann Nachfolger soll der
Amerikaner Bill Anderson werden ein
erfahrener Manager vom Pharmakonzern
Roche vielen Dank Valerie nach Frankfurt
einer der erfolgreichsten
pop-komponisten aller Zeiten bird
bäckerack ist tot er verstarb bereits
gestern im Alter von 94 Jahren in Los
Angeles wie seine Sprecherin mitteilte
für seine Werke wurde der jazz pianist
vielfach ausgezeichnet unter anderem mit
drei Oscars und sechs Grammys zu seinen
größten Hits zählte etwa diona Barracks
I say a little prayer
[Musik]
jetzt oder nie sagt der Direktor des
legendären reichsmuseums in Amsterdam
noch nie gab es so eine Schau dabei muss
der Museumsmann eigentlich gar keine
extra Reklame machen er hat bereits vor
der Eröffnung mehr als 200.000
Eintrittskarten verkauft auch das gab es
noch nie morgen startet diese
Ausstellung der Superlative dann auch
tatsächlich 28 Gemälde des holländischen
Meisters vermehrt unter einem Dach nicht
mal er selbst vermehrt selbst dürfte so
eine Galerie erlebt haben weltberühmte
Schätze und gleichzeitig der Blick in
eine rätselhafte Welt aus Amsterdam
Gunnar Krüger
es wird laut
bevor die schönen stillen einziehen
Amsterdam Reichsmuseum auf die
Mitarbeiter hat die Dienstboten mit
Milchkrug längst ihre Wirkung dass man
auch eigentlich konzentriert so genauso
konzentriert ist wie das Milchmädchen
was ich auch nicht ablenken lässt durch
all die tausend Besucher die da immer
vorstellen sondern einfach gießt und das
ist auch so ein bisschen was mit einem
selber passiert finde ich wenn man davor
steht und man schaut die einfach zu und
wird ein wenig ruhiger in der hektischen
Welt
in dieser Welt gibt es 37 Werke des Jan
Vermeer und bislang keine Ausstellung
die mehr davon an einem Ort versammelt
hätte
die Bilder von vermehrt sind alle die
Highlights der Museen die Sie uns nun
geliehen haben und das ist schon ein Akt
ein solches Bild dann auszuleihen sofern
sind ja so froh dass wir jetzt 28 hier
haben und damit eben noch einmal diese
Chance bieten für mehr mit so viel
Bildern kennenzulernen
es ist auch die Chance sie gründlich zu
durchleuchten
Restauratorinnen machten Reisen in das
Künstlers Kopf mit neuer Technik spürten
sie hinter dem Milchmädchen ein
Wandregal auf
hatte vermehr es über tüncht damit der
Blick allein auf sie fällt
folgt man eigentlich ein bisschen dem
Gedankengang des Künstlers und von mir
ist auch ein Künstler der ganz viel
verändert während des Malprozesses also
wir kennen keine Zeichnung und so weiter
also er entwickelt seine Komposition
natürlich in seinem Kopf aber eben auch
auf der Leinwand wer war Jan Vermeer
schaut er uns hier an war er so reich
wie sie der Gast wird ein Vater von 14
Kindern malte wenig verkaufte teuer aus
gutem Grund
mehr ist wirklich der Maler des Lichtes
und zwar eines Lichtes was natürlich ja
natürliches Licht in die Zimmer hinein
scheint aber er vermehrt man den
Eindruck dass man tatsächlich vor einem
Raum steht dem man betreten möchte oder
das Licht so natürlich ist und das Licht
alles miteinander verweht was er dort
zeigt
man notiere also Licht und Stille
erleben in Amsterdam bis zum 6 Juni
[Musik]
kommt so zurück in die harte Realität
nimmt uns Maybrit Illner jetzt gleich
mit die Kosten der Krise hilft der
doppelwumms fragt sie unter anderem die
Parteichefs von CDU und FDP
und gegen 0:35 Uhr gibt es unser heute
journal Update mit Nazan göktemieren
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ändern Sie sich
noch an den Neujahrstag der war ja viel
zu Milch und nicht nur in Deutschland
sondern europaweit es war der wärmste
Januar Tag überhaupt das sind die
Auswertung des Kopernikus
satellitenprogramms und wir sehen hier
lokal teilweise Abweichung von gut 16
Grad und in der Klimakrise müssen wir
auch in Zukunft mit solchen extremen
rechnen weniger extremes Wetter derzeit
in Europa hier kommt eine Delle in
unsere Hochdruck Brücke und
dementsprechend auch Wolken von Norden
Rhein die können durchaus in der Nacht
dann für Glätte sorgen bzw der Regen der
da herausfällt sprühigen und etwas
schneekriese sind dabei ganz im Norden
regnet es ebenfalls und ganz im Süden da
klar ist offen es wird knackig kalt in
der Südhälfte bis -12 Grad Richtung
Schleswig-Holstein ist es am mildesten
mit plus drei Grad morgen dann entlang
der Donau nach
örtlichen Nebel viel Sonnenschein nach
Norden hin ist es deutlich dichter
bewölkt und
örtlich kann es mal rauströpfeln das
wird nicht viel sein bei
wüstentemperaturen von 0 bis 8 Grad die
kommenden Tage werden trocken sein nur
am Samstag gibt es in den östlichen
Mittelgebirgen etwas Regen im Süden
sogar viel Sonnenschein bei ein bis zehn
Grad und die Temperaturen die steigen
etwas an drei bis elf Grad sind dann bis
Montag durchaus drin und damit ein
schöner Abend